simplifica la expresión racional e
indica cuál es el dominio y aquí tenemos
una expresión racional que es una
expresión dividida entre otra expresión
y pues si lo que queremos es simplificar
lo lo que tenemos que hacer es encontrar
cuáles son los factores de cada una de
estas expresiones y seguramente porque
esto es un ejercicio bonito nos están
pidiendo que simplificamos la expresión
entonces seguramente algunos de los
factores de la expresión de arriba van a
ser iguales a algunos factores de la
expresión de abajo y entonces vamos a
poder cancelar los y nos va a quedar una
expresión más simple y tal vez no te
acuerdes de cómo se factorizar estas
expresiones cuando el término de x al
cuadrado tiene un coeficiente que es
distinto de 1 entonces este vídeo va a
ser una muy buena práctica para
factorizar expresiones con estos
coeficientes distintos de uno ahora si
lo quieres repasar más a fondo te
recomiendo que vuelvas a ver sus vídeos
son los vídeos de factorización de
expresiones cuadráticas y los puedes
encontrar en la página de khan academy y
muy probablemente en esta misma lista
pero bueno lo que queremos hacer para
factorizar esta expresión es tomar este
término que es el término que tiene una
sola equis y dividirlo en dos pedazos
ok queremos encontrar dos números que
sumen 13 pero que si los multiplicamos
nos quede el coeficiente de la equis
cuadrada que en este caso es 2 por este
término de aquí que es 20
lo que queremos es escribir a 13 x como
la suma de a x + b x donde estos dos
coeficientes son tales que a por b es
igual a el coeficiente de la x cuadrada
que en este caso es un 2 por el término
libre que en este caso es 20 y eso es 2
por 20 es igual
30 buscamos dos números a ive que si los
sumamos nos queda 13 y si los
multiplicamos nos queda 40 ok entonces
vamos a buscar entre todas las parejas
que si los multiplicamos nos da 40
entonces empecemos por 1 y 41 por 40
ciudad 40 pero 1 más 40 no es igual a 13
entonces vamos a dividir a 40 entre 2
nos queda 20 2 por 20 es 40 pero 2 más
20 no es igual a 13 entre 3 pero 40 no
es divisible entre 3 entonces nos vamos
a saltar el siguiente 40 entre 4 es 10
10 más 4 es 14 entonces no es igual a 13
55 porque me da 48 58 es igual a 13 así
es que ya encontramos esos dos números
que sumados nos dan 13 y multiplicados
nos da 40 muy
muy bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer
con esta expresión
es dividir a este 13 x en 5 x + 8 x así
es que esto de aquí nos queda igual a 2
x cuadradas más pues vamos a ponerle 5 x
las 8 x más 20 pero vamos a agrupar este
término con este término ya esto le
vamos a sumar este término más este
término aunque en realidad pudimos haber
cambiado el 8 x y el 5x del lugar nos va
a quedar exactamente lo mismo
eventualmente y pues hagamos lo mismo
con este término no porque tenemos por
aquí el 17 x y queremos buscar dos
números que si los sumamos nos queda 17
y si los multiplicamos nos queda 2 por
30 o sea 60 entonces vamos a buscar
entre todos los divisores de 60 tenemos
1 y 60 pero no suman 17 obviamente
tenemos 2 y 30 pero tampoco nos sirven
tenemos tres con 20 porque 3 por 20 60
tampoco sirve estamos con el 4 60 entre
15 este tal vez podría servirnos no
haber 4 más 15 19
todavía no entonces con el 560 entre 5
12 12 y ahora sí
5 12 si nos da 17 así es que ya
encontramos esos dos números que si los
multiplicamos nos da 60 y si los sumamos
nos da 17 que son 5 y 12 así es que por
aquí vamos a escribir esta expresión
como 2x cuadrada y el 17 x lo vamos a
dividir en 5 x más 12 x
30 ok pero vamos a querer agrupar este
2x con este 5x y sumarle 12 x + 30 ya se
ven parecidos no pero mucho cuidado
mucho cuidado esté claro que no se puede
cancelar con este porque aquí se están
sumando no multiplicando mucho ojo no te
vayas a equivocar y ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es simplificar cada uno de estos
paréntesis y como los vamos a
simplificar pues vamos a sacar su
factorización más chicas que podamos hay
por ejemplo aquí 2 x cuadrada más 5 x
estas dos cosas tienen una equis en
común así es que los podemos escribir
como
sacamos la equis del paréntesis x
y nos queda 2x cuadrada entre x
simplemente 2x
5x y la dividimos entre xy nos queda
simplemente un 5 entonces esta cosa de
aquí es igualita a este paréntesis de
aquí aunque ya eso le tenemos que sumar
aquí a esta expresión como lo vamos a
factorizar pues el 4 divide al 8 y al 20
entonces vamos a poner por aquí un 4
y 8x entre 4 es 2 x 1
20 entre 4 es un 5 y muy bien esto está
súper bueno porque este paréntesis es
igual a este paréntesis y ese es uno de
nuestros objetivos ahora vamos con estos
plan en tesis de aquí aquí otra vez
tenemos una equis en ambos lugares así
es que vamos a sacarla tenemos por aquí
x por y 2 x cuadrada entre x es
simplemente 2x +
5x / x es un 5 día este paréntesis le
vamos a sacar un 6 porque el 6 divide al
12 y el 6 divide al 30 entonces por aquí
podemos poner un 6 por 2 x
a 30 entre 65 y ahora como tenemos aquí
este paréntesis igualito a este
paréntesis entonces podemos pensar en
esto como en un solo objeto y entonces
aquí tenemos x por el objeto más 4 por
el objeto y entonces lo vamos a escribir
como el objeto que es todo el paréntesis
que lo escribimos 2 x + 5 por x por el
objeto entre el objeto nos queda
simplemente x + 4 por el objeto entre el
objeto nos queda simplemente 4
y por aquí vamos a hacer lo mismo y
entonces nos queda este paréntesis que
es 2 x + 5 x
x x + 6
6 y listo actualizamos esta expresión
ahora aquí nos podemos ver muy tentados
a agarrar y cancelar este paréntesis con
este paréntesis porque son iguales pero
ahí es donde tenemos que tener mucho
cuidado con el dominio de hecho vamos a
descansar los si éste resulta ser igual
a cero entonces se hace un desmadre
porque estamos dividiendo entre 0 y no
podemos hacer eso entonces este es un
muy buen momento para indicar cuál es el
dominio de esta expresión porque además
queremos que esta expresión sea
exactamente igual a la versión
simplificada de esta expresión ok si no
realmente no estamos simplificando la
expresión simplemente estamos anunciando
otra expresión que se parece en casi
todos los puntos a la expresión original
ok entonces lo que queremos es indicar
para qué valores de x el determinante es
distinto de 0 ok y esta expresión que es
el determinante va a ser distinto de
cero para
todos los reales excepto para los x para
los cuales 2 x + 5 es igual a cero o x +
6 es igual a cero entonces nuestro
dominio dominio
es igual a todos los reales todos los
reales
excepto
depto a ver vamos a ver exactamente
cuáles son los valores que x no puede
tomar a ver vamos a restar 6 de los dos
lados y entonces nos queda x igual a
menos 6 y por aquí restamos 5 de los dos
lados y nos quedan 2 x igual a menos 5 y
dividimos entre 2 de los dos lados y nos
queda menos 5 entre 2 aunque entonces
nuestro dominio son todos los reales
excepto menos 6
y menos cinco medios ok entonces el
dominio de esta expresión que pues la
podemos ver perfectamente como una
función poniendo efe de equis igual a
esta expresión y su dominio es este de
aquí porque estos son todos los valores
que puede tomar x de tal forma que esta
función esté determinada y ahora sí si
tomamos este dominio y aseguramos que x
nunca va a ser igual a menos 5 medios y
por lo tanto estamos asegurando que 2 x
+ 5 nunca va a ser igual a 0 entonces
como 2 x + 5 nunca va a ser igual a cero
ahora sí ya podemos cancelar este
término con este término y lo que nos
queda es x + 4 entre x 6 x + 4 entre
y ahora si esta expresión con todo y su
dominio si es esta otra expresión
simplificada ok porque estamos
preservando el dominio aunque hay
recuerda que para que dos expresiones
sean iguales o también para que dos
funciones sean iguales tienen que tener
exactamente el mismo dominio